the life of an entrepreneur is
definitely one that has a lot of ups and
downs as of many of your guests could
attest to it you can attest I'm sure
and so what I mentioned earlier the game
soulforge we've since relaunched it but
at the time it was a purely digital
trading card game and I partnered with
Richard Garfield right this is the guy
that created Magic the Gathering this is
a dream come true for me and I'll tell
you the brief story like so we meet
we're at a game conference you know like
I'd seen him around before but we hadn't
really met and uh we're at a game
conference called Pax Dev it's like a
developer conference and he's giving a
talk on design so of course I'm in the
audience listening because I want to
learn from the master and he says at the
end there's a q a and then somebody asks
him hey what's your favorite game right
now and he says Ascension and I
literally like jump up out of my seat
from the back of the audience and like
like a stupid kid right everybody laughs
but it gives me the opening and so I go
and I start a conversation with him
after the talk and we start talking and
we get excited it's clear we're both
excited about the same project and so
soul for just born
now this was a project that was my first
digital game I'd ever done and I
was a little cocky at this point I won't
lie I succeeded my first project
Ascension was a huge success everything
I touched turns to Gold it's all gonna
be great we're doubling in size every
year
and we do a crowd fund and I thought it
was going to cost like 250 000 to make
that game
and we crowdfund with that Target and we
end up crowdfunding double that gold
near almost double that goal like five
hundred thousand dollars it's like oh
this is amazing we're gonna crush it
we're so good and as it turns out making
digital games is very expensive and that
costs three million dollars to me oh man
and so I had to go and try to raise
funds again and you know we have to
launch the game before we're ready and
again we have followers we have cash but
the cash burn is over time I can see the
cash burn is higher than the income and
it's not working and I overextend I
start borrowing more money I start
trying to like I know I can make this
work I'm not gonna let it go like this
is my baby I'm Gonna Keep it going how
are you raising and borrowing money just
if you if you don't mind adding a little
more detail so it starts off with kind
of friends and family you know
convertible notes
kind of round so that means like they
give me a loan and then in theory it
turns into a into Equity over time as we
get yeah and then after that then I
start taking some of those refactoring
loans like you talked about right so I'm
getting loans against my future income
on ascension to pay for soul Forge and
then you know starting to run up credit
cards and like all the things are really
are not supposed to do yep and I get to
a point where I have to like finally
realize like wow I'm I'm gonna go
bankrupt like I can't do this anymore
like I'm gonna lose everything and this
was just one of the hardest things that
I have ever faced because not only is it
like I feel like I owe it to my team who
I'm gonna have to lay off these people
whose livelihoods depend on it we have
fans and people who love the game and in
a traditional tabletop game if I stop
making Ascension let's say right you
still have your copy of Ascension at
home and you can play it for as long as
you want doesn't matter if I don't make
any more but when I turn on when I stop
making software it's a digital game that
means the servers turn off that means
your entire collection is gone that
means you can't play everything you
spent it's all gone so I'm like failing
myself I'm failing my team I'm failing
the fans like everything and I have to
make some very very hard decisions and
not to mention the friends and family of
course yeah I literally had my parents
had taken a loan against their house to
help me at one point I mean this is I am
so overextended I am so like in the
thick of it and shame and it is tough
and I have to
come to a realization and come to the
other side of it where I had to like go
through this process of accepting I had
to get to the other place like okay
it happened I've lost everything I
failed now what right now there's a
different kind of fear setting exercise
because now I'm on the other side of my
worst nightmare and I
you know took me a little while but it's
like okay you know what
I will still be alive
I will be able to pay off some of these
debts over time with some other things I
can recover from this it's going to be
okay the people who got laid off they're
going to get another job right like it
was not easy but then I once I accepted
that worst case outcome and then I was
able to say okay now how do I make this
less likely and so I
had to lay people off but I also
renegotiated debts and negotiated
payment plans and reduced our overhead
and took on more contract work and like
slowly but surely I was able to dig
myself out of the hole and I don't think
there's any chance I would have been
able to do that if not for being
mentally ready with okay I've lost it
all right I'm talking to bankruptcy
attorneys right and that gives you a
different kind of attitude and approach
when you're trying to you know you're
negotiating with a lender that you owe
money to they're like you owe me money
you should collect them like I know but
either I'm gonna go bankrupt you're not
gonna get anything or we're gonna work
something out and I'm gonna I'm gonna do
my best to pay you off
and so fortunately I was able to turn
that around and
not only did I learn you know the
important lessons like you can go
through a lot and you can recover from
it but also to you know not put myself
in that position again right not to
overextend to that degree and learn to
make smaller bets and grow as you can it
was a very important and powerful thing
which then of course I'm now able to
been able to come back to with
reinvigorating that very same game